over the weekend donald trump's least
intelligent son that we are aware of
that's eric trump
made some completely ridiculous and
absolutely irresponsible comments he
went on fox news
to the program of judge jeanine pirro
and said just a series of wacky things
that were either lies or wrong
he also alleged a number of baseless
conspiracies so let's
dive right into the first clip here 76
days to be exact away and
listen biden loves this biden can't go
on stage without making some
horrible blunder i mean even from his
basement he's making awful gaffes every
single day so
his campaign's thrilled that he's not
going out there and they think they're
taking away donald trump's greatest tool
which is being able to go into an arena
and fill it with 50 000 people every
single time right
so they they will so trump was not
filling arenas with 50 000 people this
seems to run in the family either
everybody in the trump family is really
bad at estimating crowd size
or everybody in the trump family is
obsessed with lying about crowd size and
of course
trump was doing plenty of rallies and
many uh
different events regularly lying about
the attendance but he didn't have any 50
000 person rallies and hilariously when
i tweeted about this
someone said it was so predictable david
when he went to india more than 50 000
people came out to see him
they came out for their prime minister
and
half the crowd left when it was trump's
turn to speak but if your one example is
from a different country
then you know that you're failing but
this is minor this is minor i want to
focus on the big thing
here's the big lie the big conspiracy
from eric trump
and you watch they'll milk it every
single day between now and november 3rd
and guess what after november 3rd
coronavirus will magically all of a
sudden go away and disappear and
everybody will be able to reopen
they're trying to deprive him of of of
his
his greatest asset um which is the fact
that the american people love him
the fact that he's relatable the fact
that he can go out there and draw
massive crowds
joe biden can't get 10 people in a room
my father's getting 50 000 in a room
so he again mentions the 50 000 person
crowd thing that that's a lie
but most importantly eric trump says
after november 3rd
the virus will magically go away he
suggests that the entire
global coronavirus pandemic is a hoax
to keep donald trump from having rallies
now here is what's
absolutely crazy about this this is
actually what republicans did to obama
with ebola in 2014.
we had four cases of ebola diagnosed in
the united states
two of those came from abroad we had two
deaths not two percent death we had two
deaths from ebola in the united states
and it was
all meant to be an attack on obama the
day after the 2014 midterms
go back and check out my clips about
this at the time
republicans stopped talking about ebola
altogether now the difference is
that wasn't a global pandemic this is
and yet eric trump believes the day
after the election this goes away
then eric trump wraps up his comment
with even more nonsense
and they want to do everything they can
to stop it so make no mistake
to a lot of them janine to a lot of them
this this is
a very cognizant strategy that they're
trying to employ it's no different than
again the nonsense that they're trying
to throw in the hope act is no different
than
the male in voting that they want to do
all these places is no different than
wanting
illegal immigrants to vote in our
country it is a cognizant strategy
um and it's uh it's sad and again it's
not gonna be allowed to happen we're
gonna win november
okay and then trump goes on to say that
reporters wearing masks is also part of
the conspiracy
if this wasn't trump's son who you knew
was merely doing disinformation
propaganda
you would question his mental state and
his connection to reality given the
wacky nature of what he's saying take a
look
look at the white house press conference
yesterday they're all in there they're
criticizing everybody why isn't
everybody wearing masks why isn't
everybody wearing masks
all of a sudden the press conference
ends they continue to roll clip
and all the reporters are ripping off
their masks in room and going up to each
other and speaking i mean
it's it's really insane i mean they're
furthering they're actually stoking fear
in this country
they're doing a massive disservice
they're being totally disingenuous about
the whole thing
but they're doing it for one reason they
want to hurt trump they tried to do with
the russia thing they tried to do it
with
you know the ukraine scandal they tried
to do it with impeachment now they're
trying to do it
with coronavirus they know they can't
beat him they know that joe biden can't
beat him he doesn't he doesn't stand a
chance so what are they trying they're
they're trying to do anything that they
can to stop him they'll shut down the
economy they'll stop in person
voting so there it is evidence that this
is a totally
fake bogus hoax political scandal that
after a press briefing
reporters remove their masks real
smoking gun you've got there eric
now let me go back for a moment to it'll
be over by november 3rd
because it's a hoax i already told you
this is what happened in 2014 with ebola
you don't even need to go back to 2014
though
go back to the 2018 midterms and that
caravan of dangerous
criminal illegal immigrants that were
going to come here and kill and sexually
assault people back in 2018.
the midterms went by you didn't hear
about it again
this is the utmost projection democrats
haven't created the coronavirus hoax to
hurt trump
it's a global pandemic republicans
really did turn ebola
which was a few localized outbreaks into
a political weapon
against barack obama republicans really
did
turn the immigrant caravan which posed
no threat or challenge to our law
enforcement at all in 2018
into fear-mongering to help republicans
in the midterms
they do that which they accuse democrats
of doing it's called projection
and eric trump sadly he's just not as
good as donald trump jr
at convincing people with his lies it's
unfortunate he's not the smart one that
we know
i want to give a quick shout out to one
of our sponsors vincero watches they're
giving my audience 15
off your entire order when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch maybe you don't usually wear a
watch and you've been thinking about
looking for one to elevate your look or
you've been thinking about replacing the
one you have
check out vincero it's an american
company all of their watches are built
in small batches from high-end materials
they look amazing
and they look like something you'd spend
a lot of money on but every vincero
watch ranges from 150 to 300
i went on their website and picked out
the kairos in white and silver
really loved the look the combination of
the white face
and the beige band really love this one
they also sent me the kairos limited
release gold reserve set
totally different style this one would
make a fantastic gift for a couple
people
i can think of in my family any time you
see me wearing a watch on the show
i'm wearing a vincero watch go through
their collection i know you'll find
something you like and you'll get 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com
watch